the trick yep he's taken it  i mean but how tricky is it bishop it's  quite tricky  because if bishop d3 does rook takes e5  and he gets rid of  his main enemy this pawn on e5 which was  really restricting  his pieces  and if bishop takes the 824 followed by  queen e5 it's just a draw sir  nice that's a very nice spot with very  limited time  i mean certainly a nice spot but i mean  is there still some danger i'm just  thinking  that the a8 pawn can start making your  way its way me ah it's way up the board  i don't think so i think it's just equal  now okay  and all the while shaq has not made a  move against rajabov so he's still  pondering over whether to  play the queen to the center to e4 or to  capture the pawn  and that's it we have a result he's done  after this b5 queen b7 good spot by  carlson what's up some pressure